jenny zigrino we can we bring jenny
zigrino back Jenny were you in that game
did you get to see any of that this is a
better face like one of those dogs like
shouldn't be alive it's like against
science and nature and then against
science and then just like it hurts to
be alive those are the best dogs we got
here completely forgive you for
kidnapping now I want to talk to you
guys a little bit is the first one that
we're doing Oh Lucky's fine look at this
actor made a giant choice am I wrong and
the award and the award he meant am i
bald
dreamy like he's not even allowed to sit
on the couch no not anymore we go at it
I've been having a real tough time none
of these shows look fun that are
drive-in shows or the streaming shows
well I'm about to do no don't say that
they're not fun it's the only thing
that's keeping me going I mean they're
fun for 10 minutes as long as you don't
do material that you love and like it
believed that if it's just like about
how weird it is in the venue then you're
gonna have the best time right so just
play this really the kim jeong-hoon game
Jenny have you gotten into any uh maybe
quarantined content shows that we're not
so fun live shows where the host is over
laughing just to keep the show moving
[Laughter]
someone had a mental breakdown on one of
those that was probably yeah they're all
a mental breakdown something's not right
when you're able to see yourself too
because people are also like doubting
everything about their facial features
there's no audience
it just really pulls the curtain back so
that leads me
next game which is canceled forever or
second season I'll give you a topic to
stand up and you tell me if it's
canceled forever or it's getting the
second season so the first one is
stand-up do you think it's canceled
forever no no no and I will say 90% of
these zoom shows are awful I'll say
Jenny and Moses and I have killed this
one and I also see other comics people
are figuring it out I think people are a
bad thing it's just I'm not
and Moses you're not I don't know how
you feel no I think the less people just
do actual stand-up and adjust to the
medium that is like what essentially a
youtuber would do yes it's great because
comics spent years talking [ __ ] about
youtubers and look at us now yes now
everyone's like you know do in front I
wish I learned how to edit yeah picked
up people like you got are you getting
cyberbully by tweens Jenny yeah because
your lip syncs hate speech it's so
spot-on and the choreography is so great
cruise ships no I think we'll survive
because old people still think it's a
hoax and they will force us to come on
the cruise ships I think they're
cancelled
they're cancelled and then they will get
a triumphant reboot a la Jurassic Park
you know I think like the go away but
what ships will attack people yeah well
[ __ ] nature finds away no you're a huge
cruise act you've been on more Cruzes
than anyone dur 78 it's true yes yes how
soon before you think you would feel
comfortable going on a cruise which I
mean honestly I'm solo right now if
someone told me to go on a cruise
tomorrow I would do it as long as I knew
is
as I knew it would get blown up before
it reached Harbor
just one last if it Viking funeral
that's how I want to go out send me out
on a cruise ship and shoot an arrow into
it castle forever
I'm gonna get a cruise going I get a
comedy cruise going is there anything
worse entertainment right just watch
hands explode
speaking of cruise ships of the phase
buffets in general canceled forever
second season you can't keep me away
thanks man I don't know I think second
season but you can't touch anything
someone else has to get all the food on
you and then you'll feel a lot of shame
and they do it yeah so you're thinking
of a food pile sort of a sort of
paleterias style I feel like but people
will travel to Florida to get that
buffet cuz you know that's where they
will exist and continue to thrive
absolutely it's gonna be like our Sodom
and Gomorrah area just like that's where
all that's where anything goes area yeah
it is we're because all these high-risk
alerts are coming out around buffets and
they're just showing like infrared
cameras of how much stuff gets sprayed
that it's a miracle at this point that
we ever even had the face like endemic
just the amount of Filth that falls off
of people's faces so just for the rare
experience that you can have lasagna and
king crab and the same plate next to
each other on the same plate yeah amen
to a buffet is too classy it's also
about just mixing the worst [ __ ] you've
ever seen in your life it's like a death
row last looks like when you were a
little and you have like they called it
a suicide where you go to the fountain
drink and you mix all the fountain
drinks together it's that with food yeah
yeah yeah and this is this is about to
turn into a mukbang this show I didn't
say that about myself
Moses slandered me and said I was too
fancy for a buffet
I yes-no buffets are great I think
they'll be around because it's the best
way to break it to your kids that you're
getting a divorce last one and this is
fudge is dirty gangbangs never been
invited sounds fun yeah nose aren't
getting canceled no yeah I don't think
so I think like and let's be clear we're
just specifically talking about gang
bangs not orgies cuz remember every
gangbang is an orgy but not every orgy
is a gangbang oh please enlighten us
it's like a square rectangle every
rectangle is a square but not every or
every square is a rectangle but not
every rectangle is a square sort of
situation because again you learn
geometry yeah that's a school bring back
orgies and bring back in your back yet
hurt immunity right mm-hmm
but everyone's City you vitamin D if you
watch those videos now it's almost like
you're watching the nostalgia CLE when
people could be that close yeah that's
like what you're getting off on is just
like general human connection yeah bruh
hugs he looks like he cares as long as
everyone's wearing PPE a gangbang could
be okay it isn't that a hot image isn't
that Oh someone in a full mask I don't
what's necessary in a gangbang okay so
these these ones I really like that were
jeans and it zipped I'm just the girl
Cooper that and then or guy or a mask
sounds yeah yeah I like shaking my penis
through a zipper it's always so calming
great to have metal teeth right there
keep it near the zipper too that's how I
do it
thank you guys so much for being here
jenny zigrino we can see you where where
could we see your you Turing again
you're on you're on Instagram Reno
Palomar tick-tock Twitter as well yeah
oh Jenny zigrino we'll put that in the
notes Joakim Boozer new season of search
party on HBO Oh max shrill on Hulu
Sony's night on Hulu sunny side on Hulu
cancelled before it's time and then Joel
you were also working with an
organization you were making hygiene
bags for people that are on housed
homeless people yeah that was with it
was originally started by resister hood
la which is an organization here in LA
and Cielo
and now I'm I'm only a volunteer but
Mitra Johari who is another comedian
here who's based in LA has sort of taken
up the cause and if you look up Mitra
Johari jou har I on Instagram she's
always posting opportunities if you live
in LA and you want to create a hygiene
kit for unhoused people here or if you
want to learn how to do that in your own
city look her up and follow her and
that's what you can do if you're feeling
restless and want to do some good yeah
absolutely because we have a lot of time
on our hands is a good time to help
people out cuz like one of my friends
said on the phone earlier this is all
terrible this is awful and that's
completely fine to feel that way but
just know that you are not alone